我今天先开始吧
好的 谢谢
我觉得讲几个事情
首先最近一段时间市场波动还是非常大的
特别是你说美股
对两方面一方面是美股
另外一个中概股其实波动都很大
包括我们昨天看到昨天晚上
上一周中概股其实是一个大涨
但是昨天晚上在美股的时候就基本上把涨幅退回去很多
包括阿里巴巴之类
就我说一下最近我对市场的一个看法
然后这个结合现在市场的主要的一个同寸
就是大家市场上那个我们说主要两个player
在美股上MutriFall和HatchFall
他们的这个市场的同寸大概是什么样
然后第二呢就是
一些政治的动态
那
大家都在主目欧洲的选举
欧洲中间最重要的德国选举
那昨天选举结果出来
那么相对来说呢德国还是偏右派胜利
就是Elon Musk支持的这个AFT
昨天获得了很大的选票
所以我讲一下我认识的就是
我觉得现在欧美的一个意识形态的变化
然后可能以后对市场或者对政治上的一些影响
那么其实在美国这个变化
然后和影响已经开始发生了
那么但是在欧洲呢也可能会慢慢发生这样的变化
然后第三呢
我想说的就是我们一直提到的就是
tell risk整体的市场的尾部的风险
或者是极端的风险
那这两天其实很多人都问到我
那么在这个市场这么大的波动的时候
特别是昨天前天美股跌了很多
那么短期里面这一周市场怎么看
然后接下去现在很简单的问题能不能抄底能不能买
我说一下我自己的头寸我自己是没有买
然后呢但是呢我还是保持60%左右的头寸
我不觉得
首先我不太觉得这一次下错是一个巨大下地的开始
但是呢我也不觉得尾部风险出境
从美国政策上来看的话
那个Donald Trump出的这个tariff
和他可能会出的tariff和他那个DOG减少赤字
这些影响我觉得没有完全被pressing
所以待会最后再说一下美国的政策的一些影响
那首先的话呢就是Hedge Fund和那个youtube on the position
我们看到其实Hedge Fund在上两周
这个表示2月22号
那2月22号国门的那个统计
所以呢就是看到上两周上一周再上一周
这两周呢我们看到this call就是相当于
两个方差以外1%的这种
1%ile的这种对冲基金的炮盘
对于对于科技公司对于科技公司
主要是对于科技公司的这种炮盘
那么tmp的炮盘呢在美国
虽然看上去很严重
但是你看整个美股的池仓的头寸啊
就是我看
美国Hedge Fund和MutriFund的池仓的头寸其实并不低
那MutriFund通常来说
他是跟着index走的嘛
所以他的这个池仓一般来说现金池仓有多少
这个代表就今天池仓不会特别不会特别高
那么但是呢现在这个蓝的线1.3
也就说明MutriFund基本上手上已经没有现金了
那Hedge Fund的Labrage在2013年之后其实一直在提高
所以Hedge Fund现在处于一个比较Labrage这种
比较Labrage比较杠杠的状态
虽然你说上两周
那个Hedge Fund卖了很多的很多的货
但是呢
我们看整体的市场的我们说
整体市场你来看是不是overstretch
我觉得市场还是overstretch还是压力比较大
这个就是贯穿了
从我们去年下半年开始说
对冲基金和MutriFund整体头寸过高
如果说发生调整
这个调整会比较深一样的道理
就是这个杠杆的累积和整体市场
我们叫市场的这个头寸的累积
这个过程其实并没有完全被这么一次
现在短期的这个调整逆转很厉害
所以大家还是在配置这些股票
那么只是在配置股票的方面上的
这个方向上有那么一点变化
也就是说我们看到Mega 7的配置
其实一直在降
包括从去年年中
去年年中Mega 7大盘股的仓卫一直在降
我们也是说大盘股仓卫降的时候
我们在做AI投资的时候
他们会按照指数曲线去炒那些application
去炒AI的应用
我上周可能讲过这个指数曲线的这个问题
就是大家预期AI的应用马上要上来
所以大家开始压住到第三阶段
就AI的应用上来去
原来大部分的比方说
Data Center云场还有提供那个
芯片解决方案的应为答案
都是属于我们叫做第二阶段
所以最早对于AI不确定
它能不能投资出来东西
那么在投资上面主要的方向
就是它的基础设施建设
和语音的建设
还有芯片那这些东西
那等着整个比方说英伟达
或者是语音的公司Mega 7的
它的这个估值偏高了以后
资金得到小盘股去了
所以从去年年中
或者是从去年下半年了
一直到现在
很多对冲基金的投资
Primebook都是在炒小盘股
或者在做这个应用
做SARS
那这些东西
它的预期会上来会非常快
因为这个我们叫做弹性
就是这些股票的弹性都很好
就你一旦真的能够应用到AI
比方说大家把Palantir作为一个目标
如果Palantir真的能应用到AI
那它的估值可以很高
然后它盈利也可以增长很快对吧
那么所以这些公司弹性很高的时候
它一般会很容易走一条这个指数的上涨
那么加上我们上次讲到
第四季度这个美国经济基本上不错
所以最后这段时间公布的很多SARS
软件小盘股公司的业绩相对不会很差
很多的资金在压住这个小盘股
那么但是整个看到市场的投蹭过高
然后加上现在开始从大盘压盘
压住到小盘科技增长
那么这个增长预期不一定会急得上
就小盘股小盘公司这个第四季度就算还可以
接下去一个季度
第四季度如果还不错
就上去年第四季度不错
那第一季度就设定的这个Tone
设定的这个基调就会比较高
后面这些软件公司在AI应用层面AI上应用
不管你DPC可能变多少便宜
甚至那个OpenAIGPD现在降下了90%多97%
甚至它也出了一个简单便宜版的
那这个这个是非常容易的
但是问题是你真正的使用的调用
和使用AI的这个改造和
最后的就是我们叫做Application变现
和它的效率提升
这个不会那么快出来
这一定是一个指数级的函数
一定是慢慢累积
然后最后爆发
华尔街要预期它一开始出现新的事物
马上就会很快的这个应用急增效率
我觉得会失望的
所以至少我说第一季度第二季度
大概率要失望
然后第一季度第二季度
大概率失望的另外一个原因
就是特朗普的政策
他的tariff对中国增加了10%
后面再增加10%
而且特朗普在这个DOG上政策
现在我会觉得越来越让人难行
因为你可以看到
Elon Musk他执行的这个执行裁员
他包括以前在推特
他执行裁员的一般的手段是这样的
就是我把他踩到出了问题
或者是没法运行了
然后我们再把人加回去
用这个方法其实推特踩了80%
但是对于一个盈利的公司
它盈利是我一目标
减赤字
比方说我们把减赤字做我一目标的话
那么确实应该怎么做
但是政府的支出两方面
第一个就是政府的支出本身有很多
并不是完全用盈利来考核的
或者是用赤字来考核的
它比方对于美国的影响力
USA的就是美国国际联合开发署
对于美国外面的影响力
包括我们说到就是
House Care
那这个东西有什么需求
其实稳定社会
甚至来说政府乱花钱
你都可以把它认为是政府的一种支出
对于GDP都是增加的
所以我上周好像讲了一个我太恰当的例子
就是好像你把海归身上的藤菇给去掉
在短时间里面
是对海归来说是很大的震动
你可以说政府会变得更有效
但是分长期的事情
在短期里面是会有很大震动
所以三四季度就一季度和二季度
真正一季度业绩要到二季度
一季度就二季度头上才开始住
那么一季度的经济的状况
和二季度经济的基本面状况
不会像我们想像的怎么好
迪欧吉硬确实要这个Doggy
确实要引起真正的关注
政策上的风险我觉得还是很大的
那么如果说这次业绩是不错的话
就是我们不要说软件的业绩是不错的话
那其实你会看到市场本身
Grambook对冲基金的投掷就已经在短
这个已经在那个小盘呢
就是我们叫InfoTec
就是小的TMT公司里面
持仓已经在增加
大的公司在减少
所以小公司的盈利
如果说后面两期业绩没有达到预期
是会有一个调整
那么时间点边说
我之前说了这三月份要开始撤退
其实我对于整体市场overstretch
然后整体市场投存过高
然后对于政策层面的风险评估不够
我觉得这个是两个主要的问题
其实真的说这个减仓
我其实上周已经开始慢慢开减仓
上两周开始减货仓
因为特别是像那些软件TEM
这些长得比较多了之后
我已经开始在做减仓
但是整体仓位我觉得还是带60左右
如果说这次软件业绩不错的话
我觉得应该继续下架
那么这个是大家问到的
是不是应该适合超底
那么我觉得不一定适合
不是完全是现在
第二个大家看到一个比较严峻的情况
就是这个wall上升了很快
wall上升了到20%
昨天晚上最高的时候到20%
我滑的时候半夜里
然后后来可能又上去了
我这边就没有滑
那个wall上升
那么wall上升大家非常担心之前讲的
就是gamma squeeze
会不会在非常短期里面
一个星期里面把S&P继续往下杂很多
这个我觉得担心有点过度
就是说第一个非常短期
比方说一个月之内的流动性来看
其实是相对来说比较balanced
比较平衡
为什么这么说呢
首先就是CTA
我们看美国的CTA大概是会卖出
那么在现在股指flat两成6000点
往下一点的时候
比较flat的话比较平的时候
一个星期大概是卖100亿
然后110亿
然后一个月大概是卖个270亿
所以这个当量你看多不多
看少不少
但是这个当量同时的话
我们有offset大概有90%到92%的公司
现在在公司回购期
所以一般来说
2月份又是他们回购比较积极的月份
就是相对来说
2月份是我们每年统计大概
I'm on top three
就最积极的三个月之一
所以大部分公司也不在
那个blackout的period里面
所以它会有一些资金去回购这股票
所以你从基本面来说
资金来说是相对来说比较flat
它非常短期的时候比较flat
然后第二很多担心gamma squeeze
就是什么叫gamma squeeze
我review一下
就是当Volvix波动率上升很快
那么原来对冲基金的策略都是卖出option
卖出期权
那么他卖期权
投行就买期权对吧
投行就相当于是Long gamma
Long gamma的时候
它的对冲就是我涨的时候就卖
我跌的时候就卖
那个对市场是一个平衡的作用
我们担心的是Vix上升特别快
就是这里Vix上升特别快
然后原来卖option那些人都平仓
因为他的女生卖Volvix
你Volvix上升他不是卖空
他要平仓
平仓的话
他要去Bolvix买回来
那dealer就会变成shogama
dealer-shogama
就高盛这些就投行会shogama
他对冲方向就反而就会暴跌
如果跌的时候才会暴跌
但是这个情况
我没觉得很严重
因为你可以看现在的这个
整体gama position
就是我们叫做
gama position是整个市场上
大家卖过的量
整个市场上卖过量
我觉得这个量没有达到
没有达到可以让Vix像去年
比方说去年比较恶心的时候
是28月份
那个时候市场的gama可能在七个
在七一个别脸
一个别脸左右吧
所以那个
那个时候就是我们会觉得
就是说如果一下子gama squeeze
那么Vix是可以跳到45只去的
现在整体的量
上周有很多expiration
有很多盗气
所以现在市场整体的量
不太支持Vix
就既有的量
因为你要把它冲得很高
大家都知道Vix会掉下来
你要把它冲得很高
到了30 40
为什么大家不卖呢
这是free money
白送钱
所以要让这些人
不在那个30 40去卖
其实你需要原来卖的人手上
已经就是做空了很多
原来去买的人
这些手上已经做空了很多
他有很大的头寸
他没有办法增加头寸
那么那个这个现在市场上
对冲基金的这个gama的头寸
不太支持能够让Vix
升到比方说30 40
我个人感觉
或者说你上去
上去到了20左右
大家觉得这个是
又到免费送钱的行情
所以又有很多人会去
卖口卖口卖口
又很多人会去买在那个位置上
比如说现在市场
大家仓慧不重
在Vix上面仓慧不重
所以这个非常短期里面的事情
来看
就一个月或者是几个星期
我觉得并并不太像
能够发生很大风险
很大风险的
更像的是在政策的不确定性
包括我们对于
经济增长的忧虑真正发生的时候
你可以看上周五
其实一个不太重要的经济数据
你当然了
上周五有COVID的传言
说什么中国又有什么新病毒什么
但是上周五更加重要的一个数据
是那个我这边没有列出来
我看看我也没列吧
好像忘记列了
上周五更加重要的一个数据
应该是那个
Inflation Expectation
Michigan的调研的
Michigan Index的调研的
就是通胀的预期
而且仅仅是五年通胀预期
超过的那点
那么市场就开始波动
就是大家对于经济基本面
那个影响
政策导致经济基本面到什么样子
大家不确定
所以在政策
政策出来的时候
它会很大的波动
但是如果经济基本面发生
方向性的这个转变的时候
它会发生更加大的变化
它会发很大的变化
所以这个呢
我觉得才是真的比较大的风险
所以一般来说
就除非说你们是在做day trading
就是每天在做交易
然后经常是买高卖
买低卖高
我个人觉得这种策略
是非常非常难赚钱
不然的话
我还是建议现在是尽管其变
在等市场的变化
网上的upside的
这个美股网上upside的空间
没有很大
就好像我上周讲的
就是我上周一直觉得
那个虽然上周好像是创新高了
虽然创了新高
我觉得它没有很大的
继续往上的空间了
所以你仓位降下来
并不太影响你的收益
往下的风险倒是挺大的
有可能会跌很多
所以手上还是要留迁进
这个是大致的一个操作
但是你说美国这些公司
包括AI毕竟是一个
确实是一个
工业革命级的东西
它中间有些非常估值很好的公司
那是不是值得长期的拿着呢
on the other hand
我觉得也是值得长期拿着
所以有一些抵操的公司可以不用懂
但是就是流动性的操作
就流动性的这个买卖仓稳
我个人是建议
在这一次业绩之后
就开始入学跑掉
如果业绩好的话
其实如果业绩不好
那你可以看
我觉得也可以跑
所以这个是我对投资三个阶段
就是我们说到
那个Semicut
就AI的投资三个阶段
在炒AI application的过程
一定是要在真正发生
一定会在真正发生前有预期
因为市场永远是预期和现实的比较
有预期的时候要逃跑
真正的实际的AI的应用绝不会这么坏
就是国个人的看法
就绝对不会这么坏
那回过来说
就跟AI的投资
因为我们说到AI application
这个是以前高尚的一个图
但我们没找到原图
我就抄了话
那个挂接见闻的
就回过来说
明天好像英伟达要报业绩
就是英伟达报业绩的话
就是首先我对业绩本身
我是相对来说比较看好的
而且我们得到的这个信息
是英伟达业绩应该是不会有什么特别大的问题
那么而且它应该是一个双bit
双bit的意思就是说它的那个
它的那个earning会bit
然后earning的expectation
就earning的预期两方面都有可能会bit
但是它的这个预期
4Q预期的收益可能在40个别链左右
就是40个别链400亿左右
那但是它的毛利会降
毛利可能在73
不是747573
Q1就一季度可能会给一个
42到42.5就是420到425
别链的400到425亿的这个预期
实际Q1可能做到440
因为现在另外一方面
中国对于这个芯片的需求也在变大
那个也有朋友去摸抵那个H20的这个需求
因为现在原来中国是没有人做training
其实现在主要也是做influence
现在有很多人尝试要去做
觉得中国也行了去试一试
所以这需求也会也会增加
就说像英伟达这种东西就是很标准的
那它是在前端一点
就要按那个Semiconductor前端一点
就是我们说更多的是卖芯片
但是一样就是市场呃
举个例子
我跟很多方manager
包括在香港呃
大的很大的基金的关于人
聊到的一个问题就是
我摸着它就是你对英伟达后面的这个margin怎么看
这这个才是英伟达最重要的问题
你的margin就是你的毛利率怎么看
大家都似乎觉得就英伟达
就英伟达对英伟达比较看好那些那些基金
都是觉得英伟达margin能够维持在现在这位置上
对我来讲是不可可想象的一件事情
维持在现在73%左右的这个这个毛利率
我觉得是在二五年二五年如果二百分之七三以下
呃百分之七十以下
然后二六年
我觉得是没有可能在二六年维持中
也就是你会看到他的虽然这个增长在上升了
但是他不是指数的增长
包括他的margin也是会下降啊
就这个是市场的一个预期和市场实现的一个差别
也就是虽然我们会看到英伟达今年
基本上能达到2000亿左右的盈利
这个我觉得是很确定
但是英伟达有两个硬伤
第一个呢
就是今年年中
大家就会开始讨论明年增长到底怎么样
二四年二五年
整体的市场是很大的
你们也可以看到最近好像
microsoft把纽约的一个那个delta center
就数据数据中心的这个list给被取消掉了
所以这个中间就是我们会问到一个问题
到了二六年到底你能够增长到哪一步
能够有多大增长
绝对不可能完成今年的这个数字的增长
今年可能60%多的增长就很难
第二个margin要下降
你的这个数据就是你的那个毛利率下降
还有一个更加重要
大家可能还没有意识到的
就是硬件相比软件来说一定是迭代更慢的
deep seek我觉得可能没有改变整个格局
因为deep seek本身是个逆向工程
逆向的那个open ai
但是你知道open ai下一代软件迭代
它会注重influence还是注重大纪群的训练
可能是大纪群训练
会不会有新的软件的迭代模型
有可能不知道
所以在那个软件的迭代快过硬件的时候
硬件永远面临风险
deep seek没有造成风险
那下一次造成风险了
所以你现在的这个英伟达的预期
和他整个估值其实是打满的
那这种状况下我觉得风险是会比较大
这也是为什么我其实一直在说
那个今年比方说年中
一季度爆出来说无论如何万一给它走掉
那现在根据市场的整体的头寸
或者是市场整体的这个仓位
比较重
就是对于这个比较重
所以我是跑掉了
但是你们比方说出了业绩之后再跑
或者是在三月份寻找机会沾略性的撤退
我觉得都是可以
但是似乎对我来讲
撤退可能会是一个更加好的选择
因为这个是川普天两天发的一个推特
他说一龙 is doing a great job
然后但是I would like to I would like to see him get more aggressive
就是他说你
他不是说一龙做的不够多
他只是顶在一龙前面说
你们觉得一龙做了很过分的是吧
但是我让他做了更加过分
就是他对于那个
其实现在美国和欧洲有一个叫做左派
和右派思潮的斗争
就是因为左右派之间的矛盾很大
其实很多时候包括我看Donald Trump做的事情
包括现在美国政府GOP他们做的事情
就是他并不是一个完全站在美国国家利益上
或者是站在西方输出普世价值观
原来过去几十年西方一直输出普世价值观
而是现在他进入一个要自我改变
自我就回到一个自我封闭的在美国状态上面去
所以他的主要敌人反而变成了
对他主要敌人反而变成了美国的相当于美国的左派
这个东西时间不足了是吧
我重新进去了